okay [ __ ] as okay [ __ ] um it's a boy
psychobabble we're playing the last of
us again I can't in this time where
you're gonna be some low weird I'm also
streaming concurrently on the witch so
um I guess I guess see what happens i
guess we'll see what happens you know um
okay well uh last thing I think we're at
the sewers like things are getting very
heated and you know if you can't take
the head like if you got a skin disease
or heat rash yeah you better leave you
know okay batches okay oh hello we're
gonna see what we come up with okay you
cool I yes be something at that I am
cool so fun i radioed are finally got
[ __ ] her on thank you I'll take this
I'll take this thank you thank you can
find something in that boat over there
yeah maybe yeah I guess uh why don't you
keep your eyes peeled okay like I que
haga I keep our eyes peeled for a while
Ike rapist like oh hello missed her
crowd hello
okay i'm looking at and what what's got
out here nice chef anything in here any
[ __ ] I'm looking for [ __ ] better
get Mike my [ __ ] got out oh ok slight
you ransom early found out her one of
them comics found another one in a
comics and it was a little bit different
in the water oh yeah see the boat now
the [ __ ] going on here at what looks
like I've dodged the chaos and the may
have like enough my time at the state is
coming to an end no what could possibly
go wrong right you happen to find my
skeleton please don't step on my see
well thanks okay it says Elton I'm
looking for it yeah
meez her skeleton hi up there how would
you bet Chris [ __ ] skeleton
oh great great Hey Hey look at you
looking Oh pendant why is it doing you
do Oh Josh shepler then go [ __ ] yourself
Josh no [ __ ] [ __ ] yourself you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know time for
horse that is one thing i do not have
time for guess we're just going about
about what is this okay shad how loud
yes i got like someone's watching my my
twitch stream that's kind of strange
that kind of feel vulnerable to [ __ ]
can't go this way you know why don't you
leave the deciding tonight batch okay
okay okay I almost did now else dad I
was that I think you're right hey it's
fine I guess how does she might your
house smells like itchy no hey Ali I
think we found something all right why
don't you tell me okay okay I think
right but he gonna check this goes all
the way through that's what I said to
your mom last night um give me ham with
same time and same time trying i'll try
go go come on kids get the [ __ ] in there
what did we just [ __ ] dropped it and
like trap them in there talking wit cha
that sexily yeah sorry I guess we gotta
love their [ __ ] [ __ ] time hey hey
flash lights out Sam steak dicks out for
Harambee dicks out hey let's see yeah
pretty gross margin my philly apartment
but that's ok
that is this John we should see what's
over here yeah yeah done there I'm not a
family ma'am you got much chance has a
porn director me neither
what is that super mice can get it open
I can crawl through and clear that door
yeah get in there kid get in there get
in there daddy says get in there and so
that's where you're gonna go I mean it's
how I gotta sides he was in a good loot
over here cuz the game does not want us
to be over here right this way what are
we just [ __ ] laughter there oh sorry
Lee well we lost the other guys Ellie I
don't know what happened to them oh we
have the loot side ain't gonna tell
alone about this I'm taking the ship for
myself okay la you keep your mouth you
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut don't even
don't tell him a thing about this
collective ego hey I've come a few
months in the world is wasting time to
shut a kick at every turn they're
infected and non-infected bank on his
back to the faux gent baby I'm kind of
shocked as I ride this long it's a [ __ ]
okay now let's see here see here like so
I've asked god good god okay so anyone
that's doing it all right now let me
just tell you a little background to
this what happened was like 65 million
years ago there's some dinosaurs and you
know they all died but you know like
luckily there's some mosquitoes that
took some blood and they got stuck in
amber anyway that's what like someone
took that like extracted that preserved
like mosquito it took the Dino blood and
they made dinosaurs trying to make like
a park but it just went all wrong okay
what is that
the snail oh no oh why does everything i
love lame man ok hello cats holodeck ads
can we get out this way yeah so hard
you'll blade and we check I have a
[ __ ] all the kids on buckets jam all
right Joe how'd it get across you gonna
say realize jello that's like um you
know why does the like priests like
these are some kind of track jam or
jelly it's because we can't jelly you're
dickin someone's [ __ ] I can going in
wow thank you tell me that after I
gather water you know
hey all right what the [ __ ] my luck and
a boy am I just [ __ ] hang out here
like I get up here I can't reach it and
I go right here [ __ ] on there
Oh what is that auctioned oh no oh no
just like a thing okay thank God I guess
henry give it a shot oh okay all right
here we go hey Jessica it's working
now let's say here let's say here
anything interesting anything
interesting now hey [ __ ] in here dad
night Shannon here baby Byron here [ __ ]
is that noise don't hear that oh they're
right there I know you're in there batch
i canna hawking up in it just for that
guy catch an angle deck let's just
change any of this broadcast what
something catchy how last of us
and temps
okay that's good it's got a weird catchy
name I'm sure a lot of people get
confused ok anyhow over here hi I don't
mind me just taking some supplies don't
make anything hmm these bad boys are
they tough life you know what I like
that but didn't know what what is that I
don't say what that does
okay hey I got a lie let's go really oh
there you go that's the mark [ __ ]
[ __ ] over that's all i gotta say i
can't wait to the house please but if i
just like [ __ ] leave around the
Senate right here okay do that work for
you
okay I guess she's not happy that's fine
i guess that's fine that mean we have to
go the way of those people over there no
we got to get the generator can see we
can spare here get the [ __ ] on there I
see that generator still got some juice
hon here goes nothing any a [ __ ] it like
to hit it that
what's moving now that says
yes all right man
work yeah don't jinx us
I should tell them right now
hey uh what about me guys is am I just
don't think we should get oh my oh she
can look now
place that place
I gotta say I'm impressed
yeah sure I'm Li Hao not even gonna say
it what's in here that's in here cats
like this i'll be taking this
what's up a lot I'm gone in uh uh sort
of alarm and someone used to live here
don't look like that's the case anymore
who would stay house girls please write
make sure they're locked after password
oh no I say learn to hang funny hit a
line ok good [ __ ] here happy taken us
thank you very much all to equipped like
I that party
what do you think different weapons in
this yeah it takes their fam oh ok
that's cool ok let's like it let's let's
be real here ok the real reason we're
here where's the drugs did you see that
let's keep it down buddy ok ok can I mix
up in here I'm gonna make this guy day
you know I am can we all this shut ok
thank ya thank ya sir No ok give me some
of us give me some of that baby oh yeah
I can't make shut with this with the
[ __ ] huh ok good good gun put that white
[ __ ] out the way
um yeah okay so let's go on here is that
maggot so no hay SE na schet elegant a
little dirty over there okay
Oh chef [ __ ] wasted enough
not [ __ ] waste that their ass well I
guess we know what happened to these
people so you know there was a kicker
with him going for a while you keep
moving forward all we can do is hope
there aren't any more of them okay where
should I go [ __ ] I'm right now I gonna
miss something okay that's right bad
yeah that is just a ska Stang that is
[ __ ] gross that's all i gotta say for
the [ __ ] meth lab what the [ __ ] is
this hello Jessica and that's Jesus hey
love this batch I could take my mouth
yeah rain catcher pellets are a catcher
good idea Halen well I don't understand
what the [ __ ] that is can anyone tell me
what the hell that is that shaking
because I still don't know what the hell
that means the shed outside
hey okay thank you thank ya lock has
gone on here what does it say Oh cat um
person that's weird wonder if I in
education system failing to the corner
and we're trapped i think it was dead a
little under with me i got infected pant
or I don't know how a whole one out
there comes down to it i'll make it
quick Jesus right the little I guess
mm-hmm
now I have a really good weapon is there
and yeah dang it yeah well I couldn't
carry two [ __ ] melee weapons like if
I could scare a shitton meadow so be
happy in this game being here now what
is that oh shut hey you think that leads
out could be it's too hot for post yeah
I'm cool how is me must have triggered
some kind of safety gate or something
and the [ __ ] down mercy we lift this and
find out so this is awkward oh you're
gonna kiss you the bars everywhere
wiggers what hey this thing is the
budget man just go get out of here yeah
Sam you stay close soon
you keep him safe go out over there [ __ ]
why don't we shoot you the bars how
great good okay okay that's great fine
okay come on kid well I don't know
something about me out of here yeah
whatever if you [ __ ] is that did anyone
else see that
okay he's coming
charts news
you
a shed
can I sneak up with him I just kill him
okay I'm chef
get the won't see me holy shet want to
run to there so come on [ __ ] where's
that runner
Alan seems are you moving oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] let's get the [ __ ] out a message
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] let's scare the [ __ ] out
of me suck my dick [ __ ] suck my job
there's okay oh Jesus [ __ ] [ __ ] slap
me
Oh
cut cut yeah I got that shot chef how
Chet eyes my control the keep
disconnecting
oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] scared this [ __ ]
out of one here where shape where is
that [ __ ] dick stuck up there
oh god I sneeze she's still stuck up
there guess where we're now [ __ ] it out
back that [ __ ] get out a smack you
ok let's talk up there get it
liz s
okis this
I only finish off this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are they
I don't know her but this [ __ ] she's
like stuck
okay here i can hate it like that a lot
of people here don't make it I say hen I
why slugs anything interesting here ah i
see earth live in a birdhouse and people
live in a people house i get it now
rubit have a batch next match come on uh
yeah
I'll taste them oh shat Joel destined
sale oh sure let me just I le get away
from the door d what it just crawled
through the hell are you doing yeah is
that loot here
let's go [ __ ]
I got damn out over here
damn thing stuck here gimme a boost I
give me that window no we got a lot of
[ __ ] here it's kind of scary open it
from the other side make it fast come on
Sam you're not staying in here what
about you I'll be fine come on go ah
shut
get ready run [ __ ] run
holy [ __ ] that was insane fresh air look
at this or night [ __ ] kidding me
packed inside did not open thanks for
the warning on either side guys so
where's this tower close come on let's
go ok i'm probably episode their dicks
out for Harambee